في هذا المعبد في تايبيه ،
تسير الصلاة والسياسة جنبًا إلى جنب مع رئيس تايوان الذي
يتنكر بشكل طبيعي عندما
أذهب إلى المعبد ، هناك المئات من
الأشخاص هناك ، لكنني سأصافح
كل واحد منهم ، فالناس سعداء بشكل ملحوظ
بالراحة التي يجب عليك تقديمها  لديهم
شعور بأن هناك شخصًا ما هناك
للاعتناء بهم تم انتخابهم في عام 2016 ، وقد
فازت psy بإعادة انتخابها بأغلبية ساحقة العام الماضي
على وعد بالحفاظ على الناس في مأمن
مما تصفه بأنه تهديد متزايد عبر
مضيق تايوان ، أصبحت تايوان اليوم أكثر أمانًا
مما هي عليه  كان عندما أصبحت
رئيسًا في عام 2016. إذا كان تهديدًا من
الصين ، فإنه يزداد كل يوم ، حيث
أن القوة العسكرية الضخمة في البر الرئيسي والتي
تبلغ قوتها مليوني جندي أقوى من أي وقت مضى ،
قامت الصين بتحليق 150 طائرة حربية بالقرب من تايوان في
غضون خمسة أيام فقط هذا الشهر ، هذه الديمقراطية التي
تضم أكثر من 23 مليونًا تحكم
بشكل منفصل  من البر الرئيسي لأكثر
من 70 عامًا منذ نهاية
الحرب الأهلية في الصين لا يزال يُنظر إليه على أنه
مقاطعة انفصالية في أعين حكام بكين
الشيوعيين الذين لم يسبق لهم أن
احتالوا  التصيد بالجزيرة الصينية قد
ضغطت على معظم العالم لقطع
العلاقات الدبلوماسية الرسمية مع
الرئيس الصيني في تايبيه شي جينبينغ يقول إن
إعادة التوحيد مسألة وقت
فقط ، هل أنت مهتم بالتحدث مع
الرئيس الحادي عشر ، هل ترغب في الحصول على مزيد من
التواصل معه
بشكل جيد؟
أن نكون متعاونين حتى
نتمكن من تقليل
سوء التفاهم نظرًا
لاختلافاتنا فيما يتعلق بأنظمتنا السياسية
،
يمكننا الجلوس
والتحدث عن خلافاتنا
ومحاولة
إجراء ترتيب
حتى نتمكن من العيش
بسلام ، كما تعلم ،
التقى سلفك بالرئيس.  xi لماذا
تعتقد أن الأمور قد
ذهبت بالفعل إلى الجنوب منذ عام 2016. حسنًا ،
أعتقد أن الوضع قد تغير كثيرًا
وأن
خطة الصين
تجاه
المنطقة مختلفة تمامًا عن تلك الخطة التي تتضمن
تهديدات الحرب بسبب اشتباكات تايوان مع اليابان
وبحر الصين الشرقي و  تشكل عسكرة
الجزر الاصطناعية في بحر الصين الجنوبي
تحديًا مباشرًا لسبعة
عقود من الزمن  .s التفوق العسكري في
الهند والمحيط الهادئ
ردًا على تكثيف الولايات المتحدة لمبيعات الأسلحة
لتايوان بيع الجزيرة أسلحة بقيمة 5 مليارات
دولار في العام الماضي ، أكد الرئيس
تساي حصريًا أن
دعمنا يتجاوز بيع الأسلحة ، فهل
يشمل ذلك الدعم إرسال بعض
أعضاء الخدمة لنا  للمساعدة في تدريب القوات التايوانية
جيدًا ، نعم
لدينا
مجموعة واسعة من التعاون مع الولايات
المتحدة في
زيادة قدرتنا الدفاعية.
زادت تايوان من 10 في 2018 إلى 32 في وقت سابق من
هذا العام ، طلبت وزارة الخارجية
مزيدًا من مشاة البحرية لحماية
السفارة الأمريكية غير الرسمية في تايبيه ،
أي وجود عسكري أمريكي كبير
أو صغير في تايوان تعتبره بكين بمثابة
عمل عدواني تقول وسائل الإعلام الحكومية عندما
ظهرت تقارير  في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر ، قامت
قوات مشاة البحرية الصينية بتدريب القوات التايوانية ،
وأصدرت هذا الفيديو
تدريبًا للقطران  الحصول على استقلال تايوان
والتدخل من قبل قوى خارجية
مثل الولايات المتحدة تحذير للرئيس جو
بايدن الذي تعهد بالدفاع عن تايوان في
قاعة المدينة CNN الأسبوع الماضي ، فهل
تقول إن الولايات المتحدة ستأتي
للدفاع عن تايوان إذا هاجمت الصين
نعم لدينا التزام  للقيام بذلك ، تراجع
البيت الأبيض في وقت لاحق عن
تعليقات بايدن التي بدت وكأنها تتناقض مع
سياسة الغموض الاستراتيجي الأمريكية القائمة منذ فترة طويلة ،
مما ترك لنا
التدخل العسكري في تايوان سؤالًا مفتوحًا
لدى الناس تفسير مختلف
لما قاله الرئيس بايدن ، هل
لديك إيمان بأن الاتحاد  ستدافع الولايات
عن تايوان إذا حاول البر الرئيسي
المضي قدمًا في تايوان ، لدي إيمان
ونظرًا للعلاقة طويلة الأمد التي
نتمتع بها وأيضًا دعم
الشعب الأمريكي وكذلك
الكونغرس والإدارة
يقول وزير الدفاع التايواني المفيد للغاية إن الصين
يمكن أن تشن حربًا واسعة النطاق بحلول عام
2025. ويقول إن التوترات العسكرية هي الأسوأ
في المزيد  منذ أكثر من 40 عامًا ،
يتعين علينا الإسراع في
إصلاحنا العسكري حتى
نتمتع بالقدرة على الدفاع عن أنفسنا
ونظرًا لحجم تايوان مقارنة
بحجم جمهورية الصين
الشعبية ، فإن
القدرة غير المتكافئة النامية هي
المفتاح بالنسبة
لنا مدى استعداد تايوان اليوم.
تجعلنا
أقوى في كل جانب
، ويشمل ذلك
قدرة وزارتنا ودعمنا الدولي للدعم الذي
عززه ، كما تقول ، من خلال
الأهمية الحاسمة لتايوان لسلسلة التوريد العالمية ،
فإن الجزيرة هي شركة رائدة عالميًا في مجال
أشباه الموصلات.كانت تايوان الأسرع نموًا في آسيا
العام الماضي.
تشير خلال
الغداء إلى أن
هذا أحد أطعمتي المفضلة
على الرغم من كل ما يبدو أنها هادئة
وواثقة من أنك تحدثت عن مدى
تعقيد الموقف حقًا الآن ،
نعم إنه معقد للغاية ، ربما يكون هذا هو
الوقت الأكثر تحديًا لأشخاص
تايوان ، أنت تقرأ بالخارج
عناوين أخطر مكان على
وجه الأرض نقرأ تقارير أم هذه
كتذكير لنا بأي نوع من هذه التقارير
التهديدات التي نواجهها وعلينا أن
نجهز أنفسنا بشكل أفضل
ولكننا لا نشعر بالذعر ،
لسنا قلقين لأن لدينا مجالس كثيرة
للغاية في الماضي ، وهي تقول
إن مستقبل تايوان يجب أن يقرره
شعبها الأشخاص الذين "  لقد عملنا بجد
على مدار السبعين عامًا الماضية لبناء
الديمقراطية الوحيدة في العالم الناطقة بالصينية ، وستكون
ديمقراطية تحت تهديد متزايد
ريبلي سي إن تايبيه